صفقات مع السعودية لبيع مائة
واحدى وعشرين طائرة بحوالي سبعة
لتتحول العاصمة الفرنسية من
مدينة السحر والعطور والجمال الى
تفوقه البالغ وهذا ما قاله
التلفزيون الاسرائيلي. اعرب
مسافر نتيجة اضراب موظفي الامن
في ثلاثة مطارات. عمال النظافة
الشراكة المبرمة بين الولايات
المتحدة وبريطانيا واستراليا ضمن
بالطاقة النووية ليعود مؤكدا ان
الغواصات تسير بالطاقة النووية
يد الرجل الاصفر حقا؟ حفلة على
شرف مواجهة صينية. هنا اجتمعوا
وهنا اقاموا حفلتهم فعن اي حفلة
نتحدث انه احتفال نووي غربي في
منافسه الجمهوري في السباق
الرئاسي بالكلب الميت. بينما شن
اربعة مليارات دولار امريكي. فهل
يعيد بايدن خسرته الكويت لننتقل
بلومبرج لتسجل الاسهم المدرجة في
بورصة الكويت خسائر سوقية بقيمة
العالم في يومين من التداول
بمقدار اربعمائة وخمسة وستين
وصف بانه تسونامي الاقتصاد
العالمي. فهل يتكرر المشهد بعد
ازفيستيا. تدهور الاقتصاد
الامريكي. الولايات المتحدة في
الجنود تدريبات على النيوبارتو
في اسبانيا كذلك. هناك تخطط كييه
العسكرية للعدو وسوف يدمرونها
فعلا وفق قوله معلنا الدعم
العالمية الثانية. ويصف كل جانب
القتال على باخموت بانه قتال
ارتيموفيسك بجمهورية دونيسك على
امل فك حصار القوات الروسية
روسيتين اقلعتا لاعتراضها ولم
تسقطاها. يبدو ان طائرة
المحتملة الى باخموت ام المعارك
الاوكرانية. حيث اعلن مؤسس قوات
الامريكان سقطت خوفا من
المواجهة. فهل تكون هذه المسيرة
البحر الاسود وتحطمها جاء بعد
فقدانها ارتفاعها وان مقاتلتين
الارضية بمن فيها وهنا اندلعت
شرارتها. حين اعلنت قيادة القوات
نفايات. ومصر تثير رعب الكيان
الاسرائيلي وصفقة سعودية تعيد
العالم باسره والخسارة تبدأ
بدولة خليجية. ترامب انه كلب ميت
مواجهات عالمية في الفترة
المقبلة. فهل الوضع كذلك برأي
البيت الابيض عن سعادته من ان
شركة بوينج تمكنت اخيرا من ابرام
المكثفة. وصل رئيس النظام السوري
بشار الاسد الى موسكو في زيارة
الاسهم الامريكية يؤججان قلق
الولايات المتحدة ويزيدان من خطر
الدفاع تهدف لمواجهة التحدي الذي
تطرحه الصين والتهديد الروسي في
اوروبا. الاحداث والتطورات. في
المانيا تعطل اكثر من مائة الف
الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيسي
الوزراء البريطاني والاسترالي
مواجهة تستمر لسنوات في اسيا هنا
القارة الاسيوية في من امرها يا
انضمت روسيا للصين في ردها. حيث
اعتبر وزير الخارجية الروسي
بعد يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة? كيف
ستردون على ارض الواقع اذا? وهنا
وزير الخارجية الروسية الكسندر
جروشكو تقليص الاتفاق لستين يوم
البنود الخاصة بتصدير المنتجات
الزراعية الروسية وفق قناة
ودائعهم في امان وان بامكانهم
استردادها حسب قوله. لكن بايدن
مليار ومائتين وسبعة واربعين
مليون دينار كويتي اي ما يعادل
مددت موسكو اتفاق الحبوب لمدة
ستين يوما اضافيا فقط برر نائب
بارد وفق رويترز. ومن حرب
البارود الى حرب الغذاء. وبعد ان
باخموت قد يستمر اكثر. حيث اصبح
الجيش الاوكراني جاهزا للقتال
بدبابات ليو برتو في ساحة
المعركة بعد اسابيع من التدريب
المالي للجيش بنحو ثلاثة عشر
مليار دولار. صمود الاوكراني في
الاخيرة على اتفاق تزويد
استراليا بغواصات تقليدية تعمل
وبامدادات لا نهاية لها. ولكن
التقدم يستمر بفضل قواته وبفضل
بنا بالحرب العالمية الثالثة.
فبرأيكم هل الحل للعالم اليوم في
رسمية الى روسيا الاتحادية تجري
خلالها محادثات مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين. سقوط المسيرة
الامريكية بالتزامن مع سقوط
اصدقاء. فكيف لها ان تمنع مواجهة
هذه الهوامير العالمية وبين هذا
الى عشرة الاف ساعة طيران وهي
طائرة رافالة المقاتلة الفرنسية.
وذاك ظهرت نائبة وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لتقول ان زيادة موازنة
على المدينة اكثر قوات المشاة
دموية في اوروبا منذ الحرب
مكب للنفايات. اصبح للقوات
الجوية المصرية اول طائرة تصل
في باريس يواصلون اضرابهم
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد
الاوكرانيين يتشبثون بكل متر في
المدينة ويصلهم الدعم دون توقف
وذلك يعد لسلاح الجو المصري
عملياتيا وتدريبا مع التحذير من
وليست ذات اسلحة نووية. الرد
الصيني جاء على لسان الخارجية
الغواصات الهادف الى مواجهة نفوذ
بكين في المحيط الهادئ. وماذا
الصينية. في بيان قالت فيه انه
طريق خاطئ وخطر هذا الذي تسلكه
وثلاثين مليار دولار بعد سنوات
من المناقشات والمفاوضات
ليصرح بايدن نحن لا نسعى لتهديد
الصين. هناك وضع المجتمع اللمسات
قاعدة لوما البحرية موجه نحو
الصين في اجتماع ثلاثي للرئيس
لا يدري ان القيمة السوقية
للشركات المالية قد انخفضت انحاء
هنا نحو الرجل الامريكي الاصفر؟
نعم. انه دونالد ترامب الذي وصف
سيرجي لافروف ان اتفاق الغواصات
ضمن تحالف يوكوس سيؤدي الى
برمته كي لا تندلع. حرب لن تبقي
ولن تذر حرب سيكون طرفيها هم
مليار دولار. وذلك بعد افلاس
سيليكون بالي وفقا لوكالة
الحياة للاقتصاد الامريكي. الحرب
العالمية تقترب. حرب يدفع العالم
نووي غربي لمواجهة الصين وبكين
ترد. مدينة العطور تتحول الى مكب
هبوط الاسهم الامريكية اليوم هنا
يخرج بايدن مطمئنا المودعين بان
وثمانية حين فشلت امريكا بانقاذ
بنك الذي اعلن افلاسه مسببا ما
بعد ان افلس بنك سيليكون بالي
لتعود الانظار الى عام الفين
هجوم مضاد في وقت لاحق في الربيع
عندما تجف الاراضي الموحلة وتصل
مئات المركبات المدرعة والدبابات
الغربية من طراز تشالنجر والليو
المكثف في المانيا وفق صحيفة زيت
الالمانية. فيما اختتم عشرات
هجوما لاذعا على ادارة جو بايدن
فايلاند؟ معها قد ينتهي الحال
بريجوجنال وضع في باخموت بانه
صعب للغاية. مضيفا ان
عنيفة في المناطق الشمالية مدينة
وفق موقع ريبار العسكري. ليصف
ضار. ليخرج الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلانسكي واصفا الوضع في الجبهة
الشرقية بانه صعب جدا ومؤلم جدا.
مضيفا انه يجب عليهم تدمير القوة
السلاح الروسي حسب قوله. واصبح
القتال الدائر منذ شهور للسيطرة
عنها. هناك في باخموت او ما تسمى
تخوض فاغنر حاليا حرب شوارع
سباق مع عقارب الساعة. فبنوكها
توشك على التاوي كاحجار الدومينو
قائلا ان روسيا تعتمد في
قراراتها لترى مدى فعالية تنفيذ
الاسود مما ادى الى تحطم المسيرة
الامريكي لترد الدفاع الروسي ان
سقوط المسيرة الامريكية التي
كانت متجهة نحو اجواء القرن في
فاجنر الروسية ان قوات كييف
تستعد لشن هجوم مضاد في مدينة
بطائرة امريكية بدون طيار اميكي
يونان خلال اعتراضها فوق البحر
الامريكية هي سببا لحرب ستجوب
العالم? من الحرب العالمية
الامريكية في اوروبا اصطدام
مقاتلة روسية سو سبعة وعشرين
اصحاب اكثر من احد عشر الف رأس
نووي. اما ضحيتها فهي الكرة
على البنوك الامريكية والازمة
الاقتصادية تشخص اعينها نحو
والاخر سيشعل الحرب العالمية.
فما يقصد الرجل الاصفر احتفال
في الاجواء الروسية والعالم يحبس
انفاسه. بخمود تشتعل والخريف يحل
خطر الحرب الكبرى يعود من جديد.
نعم يا سادة مقاتلة امريكية تسقط